thanks to LastPass for sponsoring a
segment of this video what do you think
Hollywood movies you think big actors
big crews big sets big explosions big
cameras big gear you know by this point
the Hollywood filmmaking machine is an
old well-oiled contraption with a bunch
of moving parts but then again so is a
steam engine or a blimp and you don't
really see us riding around on those
anymore I think these days the modern
way of filmmaking is like that and I
want to find the Tesla you know what is
a cyber truck of modern filmmaking at
this point there is so much technology
available to us that there has to be a
better way so I've had an idea for a
short film for a few years now but I
haven't shot it yet because it needs to
look like a legitimate movie but the way
I need to shoot this is with no budget
cheap equipment in just a couple friends
on my crew the same way you or I or
anyone else out there would have to make
a movie these days we wanted to in this
video I'm gonna show you how I plan on
getting that big Hollywood look for
nothing so that you and I can go out
there and make better films all right so
let's go figure it out together so the
short film is called you monster not to
dig up old news here but remember the
time that Logan Paul ended up filming in
the suicide for such a pan and brought
into reality something I've been
thinking about quite a bit which is how
people can lose their humanity through
two ways one always living their life
for other people's attention whether
they're going to a restaurant only be
able to take the Instagram picture or
they're doing an activity just so they
can film it the second facet of it is
what is the responsibilities that we as
an audience have in these kind of pieces
how much is a blame do we share in that
as the audience it got millions of views
we watched it we ate it up so this piece
kind of brings all it together the
stories about a social-media influencer
has made some very bad decisions in what
they've decided to use to make
themselves popular and in turn they
become haunted by us by the camera by
the fourth wall they are literally aware
that someone is watching them every
seconds of their life and it doesn't
matter where they go or where they hide
because the camera always cuts to them
and shows them and it is driving them
insane so for this piece to work it
needs to look like a movie it needs to
feel legitimate and real the drama needs
to carry weight there are times that
make sense to have a big food but that
little sliver of film making way at the
top there those Marvel movies and Star
Wars movies well there's a whole lot
between that and indie filmmakers
there's all those shows you see MTV
there's all those lower budget movies
and they're all doing the traditional
Hollywood system and it is expensive and
it is prohibitive and it's time to
reimagine things it's time to apply new
technology
things alright so these problems all
stem from old technology first things
first the camera back in the day
cameras were film cameras she had a big
ol camera with film reels and the thing
was literally mechanical eyes if she had
to have somebody who could operate the
camera he had to have an assistant
camera their job is to just deal with
the machine itself frequently that
assistant camera is pulling focus then
we have that film loader the person
whose job it is to deal with loading and
unloading film you also have a second
assistant camera operator very often
that person is the one who works the
platform this is all fine and great for
operating your camera but what about the
tripod the cameras on what about the
dolly system what about the rigging well
you have your dolly tech oh did I forget
to mention that on a Union Hollywood set
you cannot do camera playback without
hiring somebody to do it for you that's
right the VTR operator their job is to
hit the play button the camera no all
right once again it stems from old
technology fits back in the day on a
film camera it actually had to run a
second video camera that was tapped in
to the viewfinder on the camera that
video feed would then go off to a guy
running VHS tapes who's recording it it
could do playback for the director you
know working out the film Karen made
sense but it's an old holdover once
again it's old frickin technology that
is slowing things down for you monster
the camera is locked off for the vast
majority of the film a certain point it
becomes a dolly shot where it's pushing
forwards constantly and those are the
only motions in the shot there's no Ken
motion beyond that I don't want to use a
tripod this is about as light as you can
get for a tripod that can hold like a 50
60 pound rig I mean this tripod is built
to hold like 100 pound cameras but look
at how big this is if I pick this piece
of metal it's like these legs here but I
love the red but I don't want to use the
red this is too heavy I pick it up and
annoys me now
earlier this year a camera came out
camera that shoots 13 stops of dynamic
range a camera that shoots in the raw
format and only costs $1000 and only
weighs a pound and that's the Blackmagic
pocket this is the Blackmagic pocket for
K they also in the black magic pocket 6k
they're both basically the same thing
they just have slightly different sensor
sizes and shooting different resolutions
but beyond that you're getting exactly
what I've always wanted which is
tiny light camera shooting in RAW 13
SATA dynamic range so this camera fixes
a lot of problems what do I get for this
lightweight let me show you this is a
gimbal the Zi Ukraine 3 now this gimbal
with this camera lets me get basically
every type of shot previously required
specialty hardware to get and no longer
need a Steadicam the gimbal covers it I
know how to need a dolly the gimbal
covers it I no longer need a crane
unless I'm going really really high up
the gimbal covers it because the gimbal
will stabilize my shot and make it look
smooth no matter what I'm doing no
longer need a tripod cuz boom monopod
you could say it's a third simpler than
a tripod it requires a third less effort
to set up look at this footprint it's
one leg I want to be higher up I go like
this that's it and then I have a
Steadicam and then I have a crane and I
can stand on a skateboard and have a
dolly I didn't need a dolly grip I
didn't need a second assistant cameraman
I didn't have to worry about my fingers
getting pinched I didn't worry about
dropping $100,000 rig and even pull
focus with this little knob and have the
motor up here spin the lens this bit of
technology is a game changer but image
is only one half of the equation here
and you talk about sound
hello humans my name is josue Lu and
today's sponsor is LastPass LastPass
relieves the burden of having to
remember passwords hello I hear you like
to use technology personal computer
internet when was the last time you
forgot a password I am here to bring you
the technology of flash Pass you see
what it does is it encrypts your
passwords such that you only need to
remember one master password and all of
your other passwords will be encrypted
for you across all of the internet
across all of your devices you will be
much happier
LastPass allows you to autofill your
credentials on mobile sites and apps for
iOS and Android and with unlimited
password storage there's no reason not
to try it when was the last time you
signed on to a site on the internet and
had to click forgot password now
yesterday in fact daily daily LastPass
will allow you to cross sync across
multiple devices meaning that if you are
signed in on your PC you can also be
signed in on your phone if you are
interested in signing up for free just
click the link in the description below
farewell humans farewell Hayley ja ja
Rule it's Zulu and I will come again
peace peace man thanks again to bounce
pass for sponsoring my journey I think
you should go back to your planet now
alright here's our actor is doing a
scene alright sound is important in fact
sound is the most important thing in
your film set you wouldn't expect it but
it is it's way more important than your
camera departments way more important
the image it's one point that anything
else good sound makes everything else
seem like it was expensive so on a film
set I have a lavalier mic on each actor
just right up close to make sure they
capture the tiniest little intricacies
to what they're saying because you can't
go back and do it again then they have a
boom mic up on top and these three audio
channels are then being piped back to a
person at their sound station who is
then your a sound technician tweaking
the knobs and adjusting your volume it
doesn't seem like a lot of people yet
does it well don't forget about that
slate that's
the slate is part of all this you'll
only have to take a moment at the
beginning of every single shot in your
day
put that slate in front of the camera
have everybody wait clap it down and get
out of the shot you know take a little
bit time of the state might not seem
like a big deal but if you take 30
seconds on every single shot you do 40
setups well you just had 20 minutes of
your day just go to filming a slate not
to mention having to take the camera out
of your setup getting the slate and then
putting it back in this up not always a
big deal but it does add up and then
later on in post-production you have
your assistant editor who is on a
computer and then has to synchronize all
your sound so some department has become
your boom operator your sound technician
slate and an assistant editing in post
so I need to eliminate some people from
this here's how I'm going to do it so
I've been thinking about this for a
while so usually we don't worry about
sound too much in a corridor video cuz
most of its action based but this one is
not it's drama I need to have clear
crisp audio from each actor so how am I
gonna do it the microphone on the boom
is Wireless so this runs back to a
mixing board and the mixing board is
recording multiple tracks so we'll have
lavalier mics on each actor I'm wearing
one right now and we'll have the boom
mic all three of these microphone
sources will go to our mixing board our
multitrack recorder wirelessly no wires
getting in the way we have a person on
that mixing board listening and we'll
even have the boom operator listening
with Bluetooth headphones so they can
hear if they're getting good audio or
not that mixing board will record all
three audio tracks back in the day you
got to use a slate bin to sync these
audio tracks to the video but I'm not
going to do that I'm using a program
called the Vinci resolve recently I used
to use it for color grading as wonderful
color grading tools I'm sorry to use it
more and more for ending and it has a
feature where if you have your audio in
camera in some way you can then take
your other audio files and have the
program automatically synchronize
everything just by looking at the
waveforms just by listening and going
you're all these sound about right and
then just doing it it's nuts it's magic
what I can do here is I can run all
these audio channels into the mixing
board I'll throw one more wireless
microphone link on the mixing board to
the camera and record a mix down of all
that audio into the camera I won't slate
all I will do is say the name of the
shot out loud before each take I roll my
shoot I roll the audio with all the
shots get the shots don't worry about
slowing down for slate and then later on
in post-production synchronize
automatically that means we can now
capture clean professional audio with
multiple
channels without having to use a slate
sound mixers and sound utility and all
that kind of stuff it's all eliminated
it's just good clear audio all synced up
for editing alright next big department
lighting now look we have lights there's
a light right there
look at this we have big softbox are you
already have two lights in this room and
there's not even a crew here how the
heck did we do that
alright let's talk about lights alright
you might think lighting is simple it is
not film shoots old technology they like
to use big old lights they're starting
to use LED lights but there's still a
lot of big old lights being used you
know why because they have big old
cameras they need big ol photons hitting
their sensors they don't have little low
light sensitive things I can just work
with whatever they need big ol lights
big old lenses shooting big old beams
you have holes of a big ol light a big
ol stand you know who cares a big ol
saying is the bagel and grapes anytime
you see a dude and cargo shorts on a
film set he has a grip actually these
guys they are responsible more
responsible in a way for people's safety
unset than anyone else they will never
ever take [ __ ] from people for that
reason and it's good because you're
dealing with a 80 pound light at say 200
degrees Fahrenheit on a 60 pound stand
if this thing falls over it is that
you're going to kill somebody or light a
fire or kill somebody by lighting them
on fire so 10 Cloverfield Language all
takes place in a room by the way has 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 12 grips to make
sure that their lights are set up okay
12 people to hold stands that's crazy
but can't get any worse than that right
well guess what lights need electricity
and these lights need a lot electricity
you think you just plug them into a wall
you'd be wrong
these lights have big honkin cables
going down the big ballast boxes these
ballast boxes then go out with his big
thick wires to something called a lunch
box and those go out to a diesel
generator literally on a trailer parked
outside with a security guy to keep an
eye on it generally speaking you're
doing a dialogue scene indoors do not
need any of this not anymore
all of this can be eliminated too
simplified and you can get the same
results here's how Nick I'm over here
over here hey what's up on this side of
the room now lights are kind of
something we take for granted right LED
lights have been coming out they've been
kind of a thing for about the past seven
or eight years on film shoots but the
thing is they've not been super widely
adopted partially because they're not
super bright yet check it out really
cool thing about LED
you can change the colors and it's
magical OOP look I can have any color I
want and you know what another cool
thing about LED lights is it's not hot
it's not even more what's this it's not
a battery wait there's no wires this
whole thing so light I can hold it with
one arm Wow so many problems solve
through the use of technology lights
themselves don't actually have to be
bright you just need to be bright enough
to give you an exposure that you want to
work with so I am going to light and
shoot this scene with a camera that
gives you low-light abilities so I can
use dimmer lights smaller lights and
that means no generator no fire marshal
no electric distribution to worry about
no heavy stands to worry about no heap
to worry about no gels to worry about
done I don't want to forget the
simplicity of being 14 years old and
having a camera and just going out and
trying to get a shot oh it looks good
beautiful you have eliminated all the
barriers between your creativity and
imagination and getting that realized in
real life that's the goal all right so
the short film has been shot we pulled
it off our crew was so small we couldn't
even have a BTS guy for now I'm gonna
break down what worked what didn't quite
honestly I'm actually super excited
because it seems like all these plans
all these crazy experiments we did
actually seem to have worked out so
let's talk about this for a second
first things first these days every
shooting on digital cameras but the
thing that people don't realize with
digital cameras is you still need to
develop your picture just like how you
had to develop your picture with film
I'll give you a quick rundown it's very
very simple as to how you do it now
right on the camera this is what it
looks like it's kind of flat but it's
set for you to do your own adjustments
to it I'm going to use a lookup table
from evil to BAP iwl TBA P which is one
of our favorite packs of look-up tables
and a look-up tables basically a filter
like something you might see on
Instagram and with the Blackmagic can
actually load these look-up tables these
filters basically into the camera and
shoot with it on so you can see how it
looks on set and adjust your lighting
accordingly so it's a perfect example of
new technology that's changing the way
we do things this a little bit of
adjustment makes everything looking
really good and really filmic and it
looks like it's been shot on a movie
camera can carrots aren't expensive
anymore these days the Blackmagic 4k is
only $1,000
all right the next thing is lighting
notice that this actually looks pretty
dang good I'm not gonna lie I'm pretty
happy with it
Adrienne did a great job two things that
we did here one we used a hazers there's
a little bit of haze in the room it
helps separate the foreground from the
background and give depth cues to your
eye you can see how there's a background
that's behind the actor and there's a
foreground and you can kind of feel
those layers in the atmosphere the
atmospheric perspective if you will so
that heiser not expensive and it goes a
long way towards making stuff look
cinematic kind of gives you that that
depth that you really only see in movies
it gives you light beams from the
windows it looks really good and I'm
really happy with it so you might
remember me mentioning that I want to
eliminate a bunch of complications
around sound I didn't want a clapboard I
didn't want to have a person on set who
had to do that so did it work oh yeah it
did it was great I'm so excited about
this this is like gonna be the newest
addition to or the way we deal with
sound on set using the waveform analysis
lined it all up automatically using
DaVinci Resolve features so we look here
at these waveforms we can see how the
waveform is all lined up awesome because
I no longer have to use a clap board to
find a visual sync point for things I
can just use the cameras scratch audio
or the audio would pump into it to match
that to the audio recording because all
the waveforms should line up it worked
so well like now we can record audio
from bunch of resources on set seek them
all up automatically I don't have to
have an AC with a slate on camera I
don't have to slow down for any of that
I can just roll and roll and roll and
that is a game changer so I'm really
excited with how this is turning out the
footage looks great all the experiments
worked and now it's just on me too
hopefully I've told a good story and
make it good at it it's gonna come out
probably in January so please consider
subscribing so you don't miss it if
you've never been to the corridor
channel go check it out youtube.com
slash corridor yeah that's where you put
all our short films and you know
subscribe to the corridor crew channel
while you're at it you know give us a
two-for-one special you're mashing the
subscribe buttons these days in this
period of Christmas or Kwanzaa or
Hanukkah or whatever it is that you
celebrate you know winter solstice pagan
holidays it's all good I'm down